Speaker 1: All right, everybody, I have for
you a truly bizarre clip of Marjorie GREENE
and Matt Gaetz talking about a weird fantasy
of something or another.
And I just need to apologize up front before
we look at this.
Some percent of you are going to, but whenever
you watch this, you're going to throw up.
Um, not really.
You'll be fine.
But it is.
It's crunchy.
So let's take a look.
Speaker 6: Favorite member?
Speaker 3: I have a phone.
I'm on record.
He set the top for me.
Speaker 6: Like, I would rather give Nancy
Pelosi a sponge bath than endure, like, one
dinner.
Speaker 3: That's disgusting.
Speaker 6: Totally.
But but.
Speaker 3: Just to just to bring this, I don't
have to.
Speaker 6: Call out for you, okay?
Like like a lot of people would say maybe
Pelosi is their least favorite member.
No way.
Speaker 3: What happened to Martin Luther
King?
Did you turn Martin?
Speaker 6: I would trim her toenails with
my teeth before I would go to dinner again.
Speaker 3: That's really impressive, chef.
I should say.
So here's how I feel now.
Speaker 1: I know some of you will watch that
and be like, it was weird, but why are you
making a big deal?
First off, it's just kind of a fun story.
A lot of heavy stuff lately.
Let's laugh at a couple of goofballs, but
also there is a larger important point.
So first, let's just go through how weird
what they were saying was for some reason
to express his hatred for Adam Schiff.
He had to do some big, long fantasy about
giving Nancy Pelosi a scrub down bath and
then biting her toes toenails.
I don't know why that was so specific and
seemed kind of preplanned.
Maybe something he's thought about before,
but really weird.
So that's that.
But then the larger, more meaningful and serious
point is this is a great example of how right
wing politics has gotten so far away from
serious discussions about how to address problems
in our country.
And I know you know that, but watching clips
like that really remind you of it.
Marjorie GREENE doesn't have any committee
assignments.
She's not working on policies each day.
She has her one vote in Congress.
But besides that, she's not really doing much.
And what she is doing is being a little media
figure.
And that's what we've seen a lot of these
Republican politicians become.
It's not about policy.
It's not about implementing.
Policy that will help improve the lives of
your constituents?
No, it's about being a media figure.
It's about being an influencer.
She has a little mtg live.
That's what it's about.
And so right there he's being a little funny
guy, you know, saying some weird stuff that
might get his audience to laugh.
Being completely unserious and not at all
trying to address the many, many issues that
need to be addressed in our country.
And so while the core reason I want to play
that clip is because it's just absurd.
And let's just think one more time.
One more time about.
Matt Gaetz saying he would rather give Nancy
Pelosi a scrub down bath and cut her toenails
with his teeth.
Good.
Then go out to dinner with Adam Schiff.
I don't think he's inviting you, Bubba, but.
Okay.
Bizarre, but also an indication, like I said,
that they don't care.
It's not about it's not serious.
This isn't about making change for their constituents.
They're just trying to go viral.
They're trying to be provocative.
Trying to be the biggest name in the Republican
Party.
Tweet out stuff on the lips.
That's what it's really about.
It's no longer at all policy focused, and
that's super duper sad and something we need
to continually call out.
And we need to demand of the politicians we
like and support that they stay focused on
the real issues.
I appreciate The David Pakman Show having
me fill in today.
It's been an absolute pleasure.
I'll just plug one more time.
Go check me out.
Luke Beasley on YouTube.
We got a lot going over there.
You can also listen to the show as a podcast.
Just Luke Beazley.
Anywhere you go, you should be able to find
me Instagram, Twitter.
All those good things.
Luke Beazley on Twitter and I will hopefully
see you guys in the near future.